il s'agit d'une journée de rencontre
d'affaires entre des créateurs de
start-up et des investisseurs en
amorçage spécialisant d'amorçage
ce sont des projets présents du plateau
de Saclay de la du périmètre de l'EPS
établissement public Paris Saclay qui
fait partie des financeurs et des
acteurs qui nous avons travaillé pour
l'organisme de cette journée
tous les créateurs ont un planning de
rendez-vous avec des investisseurs pour
les aider à renforcer leur fonds propres
pour que leurs projets puissent prendre
la dimension nécessaire à une croissance
convenable et internationale global
comme toute société devrait être
aujourd'hui
monter un rendez-vous en face à face
avec des investisseurs c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas si simple que ça et
donc on l'offre aujourd'hui au créateur
où tu le président de la Société fitel
la technologie fit elle permet de
numériser tous les vêtements en 3D qui
existent sur tous les sites qui existent
actuellement
on récupère des informations qui nous
permettent après de recréer le vêtement
en 3D
utilisateur en 3D à partir de 4 photos
et à partir de ça en recréer
l'utilisateur en 3D du coup
l'utilisateur peut essayer sur lui des
vêtements en 3D
on est très heureux d'avoir pu remporter
ce prix qui montre en fait que l'idée
également rencontre petit à petit son
public
plusieurs des associés de la boîte sont
issus de l'école polytechnique qui est
sur le campus Saclay je suis même un
petit peu mais amateur spécialisé de
centrales Paris qui va rejoindre Paris
Saclay donc c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir cette écosystème là qui non
seulement soutient l'innovation et qui
en plus regroupe en un seul endroit les
meilleures écoles françaises ou crayons
pôles de compétitivité au niveau mondial
on sait qui storiquement on a toujours
dans les trois six mois au moins 20% des
projets présentés qui lèvent et qui vont
développer alors soit ils vont se
développer eux-mêmes et on continue leur
croissance on a plusieurs projets qui
ont continué qui sont devenus des
sociétés de bonne taille et puis
d'autres ce projet qui se font racheter
et qui vont par des grands groupes
industriels ou ce genre de choses et qui
vont poursuivre une autre façon leur
développement